all right people
today is january 20th 2022
and it is a day that will live in infamy
if you are awoke whack-a-doodle because
the reuben report starting today
is now officially live every weekday at
11 a.m eastern
from the city of miami in the free
state of florida we are in my house in
our new temporary
studio this is just a temporary studio
with a temporary background and a
temporary table and temporary desks and
temporary workers i meant to tell you
guys that before we'll deal with that
later
while we build out the main studio it's
going to take a little time because i
don't know if you've heard about this
but there's some supply chain stuff
going on because of this old senile fool
joe biden let's go branded by the way
so it's going to take us a little time
to build out the full proper studio so
we're using the the screen background
there we've rigged this whole thing
together we literally got the keys to
the house at about noon yesterday
we had boxes and wires and computers and
ikea stuff and it was absolute
madness a mad dash to make something
happen but we ran a test show last night
which uh thank you guys for all the fine
compliments and i'm glad that many of
you uh drank dave's famous paloma i saw
a lot of you doing it with me so we did
that last night you can check that on
youtube or on rumble if you want to see
what we were up to last night that was
really just a test run to make sure that
everything was going to be okay this
morning
i don't need to repeat myself but i am
very happy here in the free state of
florida okay was i looking down a little
bit right there i should be looking up a
little bit right that's what there
there's the camera over there okay sorry
about that
um i'm very happy here in the free state
of florida things are great and i just
know that everything we're doing
in terms of this show but also the ideas
that we're fighting for they're just
gonna flourish here i feel it i feel a
weight off my chest i feel reborn it all
sounds sort of cliche
at some level but it really really is
true so most importantly guys
i want to ask of you today
whether you're watching hopefully on
rumble but if you're watching on youtube
of course if you're watching on blaze tv
just make sure that you're actually
subscribed and you can set some
notification whatever it is that you do
to know that our show is now live at 11
a.m eastern which i think is actually a
better time for everybody it's a little
earlier in the day on the eastern side
for the people in the on the west coast
uh pacific you know you're doing an 8
a.m situation but i think you're gonna
work it out you're getting your coffee
ready you're pulling yourself together
and you've got dave in the background
what a wonderful way
to start the day uh so we got a couple
stories for you today oh and by the way
i will
stick
to my commitment from last night i
committed last night that if i going
forward on this program if i
gratuitously bring up california which i
guess i just did right now so i now owe
five dollars i will put five dollars in
a fund i don't want to think about
california anymore okay i'm done with
california i am on to greener pastures i
am on to the everglades now i am on to
freedom country so if i just
gratuitously bring up california oh woe
is me i lived in california there's a
lot of homeless people and everything is
really falling apart and the taxes are
high and there's this really bad man
named gavin newsom and he's very scary
and i think he's a psychopath
if i just bring up that place for no
reason
i will put five dollars every time i do
it for the next year into a fund and at
the end of that
at the end of the year we will see how
much money is there and we will figure
out what to do with it i don't know if
it's going to the california refugee
association i don't know if i'm just
going to hand it all to larry elder so
he can get a truck and get the hell over
here and get out of there we're going to
figure all that out but that is my
commitment
going forward anyway one last thing and
then we'll start i just as i said last
night i'm super psyched to be back in
studio i missed you guys i love what i
do i miss talking to you about the news
i missed communicating one way or
another we did a lot of stuff in our
locals community uh but i missed the
show i missed the show the world is just
nutty it's just how it is it ain't gonna
get less nutty at least for a while and
uh for all of you that tune into this
thing to just like pull for a little
sanity out of it it's like it's a
two-way street because i get it from you
guys too so i'm super psyched to be back
and uh thank you to my whole team and
everyone that just helped us in this
last month it was a crazy month of
moving and you guys know moving getting
a house like it's all it ain't easy
especially cross country
and then covet and all the stuff so it's
all good we got a great show for you
today we're going to show you some covid
madness from mainstream media first this
don lemon guy you know about him
ridiculous guy over on cnn we used to be
friends sort of he used to go out to
dinner every now and again he's just
lost his mind then there was this crazy
story out of npr yesterday that neil
gorsuch basically the supreme court
justice was trying to kill sonia
sotomayor because she's got diabetes and
he didn't want to wear a mask turns out
basically to be false but that did not
stop our friends on cable news
cnn the comedy channel cnn and the
mental institution channel msnbc they
had a ball with it so we'll review some
of that stuff uh then there was really
some crazy video it went viral yesterday
and i thought it was uh important to
show you guys some really crazy video
out of canada
out of quebec on a tv show it's in
french actually
where a bunch of kids start talking
about sort of what we should do to
unvaccinated people and if you don't
think that there is
sort of cascading damage to what we've
done to society what we've done to
ourselves psychologically what we've
done to children
two years into lockdowns and mandates
and infringing on people's rights and
everything else this will this will
truly put a chill up your spine if you
haven't seen it i mean it is it is and i
don't use it lightly it is nazi germany
style propaganda that kids are now
repeating i mean really crazy stuff and
then finally i thought it would be a
nice way to wrap up our first show at
the new time here in miami florida uh
just talking about the mass migration
happening across the united states it's
absolutely extraordinary when you really
see we're going to show you a map with
some numbers the amount of people that
are fleeing blue states of course going
to red states and then on top of that
because these things are not
disconnected
we're going to show you some stuff
related to people that you're not going
to believe this they're moving away from
the democratic party they're moving away
from the hysterical authoritarian
progressive insanity and they're going
to a republican party that ain't perfect
and sometimes it's a little weird and
never really does as much as they should
and never really live up to their ideals
but they're not completely bananas so i
think that's net good so uh that's all
i've got to say about that and before i
get to any of that i want to talk to you
guys about jen you sell
uh here we go we don't have all of our
stuff yet am i doing jen yourself first
where am i going i'm going jan yourself
first oh there we go i put it i put it
last in my notes okay here we go guys
you know what the real secret to
effective world-class skin care is it's
the goodness of a creamy one-of-a-kind
base that absorbs easily into your skin
to target those forehead wrinkles laugh
lines crow's feet under eye bags and
puffiness and yes even a sagging jawline
geniuselle's calendula flower base was
formulated by a pharmacist to deliver
specifically researched ingredients to
the areas you want the most it's hard to
pick one thing i like most about their
products it could be their lightweight
feel how smooth they make my skin or
even their fresh scent their crystallis
microdermabrasion treatment smells like
orange citrus and with janusel's
immediate effects you see results in 12
hours guaranteed that's right jen
yourself promises results that you'll
fall in love with each time you look in
the mirror or you'll get a hundred
percent of your money back now is the
time to try genusell yourself and see
life-changing results like a million or
like millions of others just go to
lovejaniacell.com dave and order and
save over sixty percent on januselle's
most popular package and your genusell
most popular package order includes the
genusell revitalizing night repair cream
free at checkout that's love
g-e-n-u-c-l-e dot com slash dave
lovegenusell.com
dave and now
back to me so because of mr joe biden's
supply chain stuff we don't have our
teleprompter yet actually technically
we've got the teleprompter i'm using it
as a desk right now but we don't have a
tripod that can hold the teleprompter
because regular tripods that we've got
right there it needs a little more
weight yadda yadda on monday
i won't be holding notes
okay so let's talk about this don lemon
guy so he's on the clown network known
as cnn and don lemon often
refers to himself as a journalist and i
thought for a moment maybe we should
just talk about what a journalist is or
at least what a journalist is supposed
to be or what we used to think of as
journalists and journalists would be
people who would be out in the field
impartially collecting information on a
story to report the truth to somehow go
somewhere
see something that happened talk to
people who were part of whatever it was
that they were reporting on and give you
a truthful honest appraisal of what
happened now journalism to that degree
is almost completely dead like there is
nobody that is an anchor on any news
network that is a true
journalist now it's interesting because
on fox usually they sort of tell you
that they're opinion people especially
at night tucker is not pretending that
he's a journalist he's obviously giving
you his opinion as he presents
information but don lemon has repeatedly
on cnn said that he is a journalist
but he is not a journalist he is an
opinion maker who pretends he's
reporting things impartially impartially
and he simply does not i say all of this
to also say that don and i
used to be friends don had been on the
show years ago we've been out to dinner
a bunch of times and then one day he
basically unfollowed me on twitter and
that's it it's okay i don't really care
about that like it's not important i'm
just mentioning it because it's just
like a little piece of the puzzle here
uh but don lemon was over on cnn
yesterday and just listen to the sort of
hysterical lunacy that he's saying and
tell me does this seem like an impartial
way that someone might report what's
happening in the world right now or does
this sound like a crazy person i've
gotten criticized for saying that we
need to stop listening to the people and
they should not be part of um polite
society so to speak you cannot expect by
the way he is all of us you know i want
to get up i want to say yes you're
jealous now right i'm mad as hell i'm
not taking it anymore basically that was
that moment he's right
he's right listen the unvaccinated
people in the u.s they're key to the to
the reason that coronavirus the variants
are emerging um and that the reason i'm
looking at the stats from the cdc and
the reason why it's replicating and and
mutating it's because of unvaccinated
people who are doing their own research
online i can't do my own research better
than experts who's who have devoted
their lives to medical and and
scientific research when i tell people i
said you know they'll say well i've been
doing my own research and uh last week i
was in miami i said how did you get to
miami i flew that's science
so if you don't believe in science why
didn't you walk
right if you it
is well because i can't always follow
the science that's the reason that
you're here that's the reason that you
don't have polio that's reason we don't
see polio cases that's the reason why we
don't see smallpox cases is because your
parents had the wherewithal and the
sense to get you vaccinated as a child
so i don't told
that you had to because what we have to
start doing things for the greater good
of society and not for idiots who think
that they can do their own research or
that they are above the law and they can
break the rules
australia
novak djokovic
australia said no no no
we're going to look at the greater good
of everyone in our society and you're
not part of that
oh man i mean whatever you're thinking
as you were watching it it's like what
do i need to add to that i mean first
off is he a journalist did that strike
you as he called people who do do their
own research idiots did that strike you
as something a journalist might say
i am not a journalist nor do i pretend
to be a journalist
but i believe and this is going to be
kind of crazy guys and you'll have to
look into this later but i believe that
people who do their own
information finding their own fact
checking their own research
i think those are usually the bright
people i think those are the type of
people i want to listen to i think those
are type of people i want to talk to i
think those are the type of people who
we should have more of in society as
opposed to the sort of brainwashed
masses that someone like don lemon loves
of course he also quotes the imad as
hell and i'm not going to take it line
from the movie network which you haven't
if you haven't seen the movie network
it's a classic i think it was 1979 can i
get a year on that i believe it was
around 79 it is an absolute
extraordinary movie i think they were
going to remake it a couple years ago
i'm not sure what happened but about a
news anchor who just can't deal with the
[ __ ] anymore the political [ __ ]
what's happening happening economically
in the country all of the nonsense now
this is back you know like 40 years ago
basically and there's this great
incredible scene maybe we'll play it for
you tomorrow where he yells i'm mad as
hell and i'm not going to take it
anymore meaning you've pushed me far
enough all of the bs has pushed me far
enough don lemon is using that in the
complete reverse way because what he was
referring to
at the top when he's talking about this
guy he's referring there was a video
that came out of a german man
hysterically screaming at a bunch of
unvaccinated people by the way don lemon
also completely lied about this thing
that joe biden says all the time that
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and it's the unvaccinated causing new
variants i had never heard that one
before that was a new one um
so
well don't watch cnn don't watch cnn i
guess that's it thank you very much
network came out in
1976 and if you have not seen it you
absolutely should that's it we're having
a reuben report movie night sorry guys
no more of the star wars nonsense we're
doing network uh 1976
great great movie i believe maybe it won
an oscar i think it won a couple oscars
not important right now anyway don lemon
is a ridiculous person but if you think
don lemon is the only ridiculous person
sort of out there pretending to be a
journalist well then there's this thing
called npr national public radio and
it's partially at least funded by us the
taxpayers and you would think that if we
the people are funding
news if we're funding journalism that it
would be impartial because it's for all
of us and we're all feeding into it
that's not how it works people
npr had a report that basically said
that
supreme court justice neil gorsuch who
is vaccinated but just chose not to wear
a mask that in essence he's been in a
fight with sonia sotomayor who's also a
supreme court justice because she wants
him to be wearing a mask she of course
is vaccinated well but she has diabetes
so she wants him to be in a mask because
you know whatever you want someone else
to do with their health and put on their
body and everything else you know it's
now up to you that's more important than
what they want anyway this story went
bananas yesterday like everybody was
saying he's trying to kill her and it's
horrible and everything else but then of
course it basically turned out not to be
true so even the new york times the
failing miserable propaganda outlet all
the news that's fit to make up the new
york times even they had to sort of
backtrack from it we've got some info
from the new york times i don't get to
quote them that often on this show in an
unusual joint statement on wednesday
justices sonia sotomayor and neil
gorsuch sought to rebut reports that
justice gorgeous's refusal to wear a
mask at a supreme court at supreme court
arguments has created a tension between
them reporting that justice sotomayor
asked justice gorsuch to wear a mask
surprised us the statement said it is
false while we may sometimes disagree
about the law
we are warm colleagues and friends a few
hours later chief justice john roberts
issued his own statement i did not
request justice gorsuch or any other
justice to wear a mask on the bench he
said since the justices returned this
month from their holiday break all of
them started to wear masks in the
courtroom except justice gorsuch
and now what you might find interesting
about this you're not going to believe
this guys this one are you sitting if
you're if you're
standing while you're watching this you
need to sit right now because
cable news the pundits what did they do
with this story well take a look
anti-mask insanity has now reached the
highest court in the land neil gorsuch
is prioritizing his right to be a tool
over protecting sonia sotomayor's life
gorsuch loves coven which makes him the
perfect perfect republican he thinks
very little of coronavirus precautions
gorsuch has the nerve to refuse to wear
a mask indoors while seated next to his
colleague who's vulnerable to possible
death from a highly communicable disease
where's the collegiality where's the
common sense that just seems ridiculous
can you put a mask on seriously polite
what kind of workplace is this it's not
hard justice gorsuch had to know that
this would become a public controversy
and so i think he did this as a branding
opportunity what's up with justice
gorsuch if all of the other including
all of the other conservative members of
the court are willing to go along with
this
why not him every other justice is
masking up even clarence thomas who
doesn't seem to care about anybody
but nope
not gorsuch he could not be bothered to
extend a life-saving courtesy to his
co-worker it not only displays a lack of
basic civility as a co-worker but also a
lack of humanity while gorsuch's
behavior here is pretty disgraceful i
guess it shouldn't be that surprising a
prickly justice not exactly beloved even
by his conservative soul mates on the
court confirmation of what we all
already knew whatever you think about
mass gorsuch who sits next to sotomayor
at work just decided to be a dick to a
colleague neil gorsuch's shame on you
shame on you
i mean those are all horrible people
they are propagandists and liars the
story turned out to be false
but it's one of those stories where even
when you start hearing about it i was in
the middle of a lot of stuff yesterday
unpacking and everything else but as i
saw it coming across twitter it was like
this doesn't even ring as true but they
all use it for their political purposes
so i get it joy reid should just be
putting a mental institution in a padded
cell like you really she should be
studied truly
but the rest of these people yes he
really wants to kill her and also if the
vaccines work and he's vaccinated
gorsuch and she's vaccinated sotomayor
and she's wearing a mask why would he
also have to wear a mask and these liars
and that's all that they are it's like
they're in studios not wearing masks
they have co-workers who might have
diabetes who might be fat who might have
a whole bunch of other stuff going on do
you think they care and do you think
they wear masks when they're at
restaurants and breaking all the rules
that they are telling you and of course
to reference the earlier story don lemon
said this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated right it's unvaccinated
people causing new variants except
they're both vaccinated so they're
sitting next to each other and she's got
a mask and they're both vaccinated so
what really is going on here and just
more than anything else that they would
dare say things like she wants them
to
die right that he wants her to die like
do you think that perhaps that's a bit
over the top but these are ridiculous
people who have brainwashed millions and
millions of people
and it's our job to fix this we must fix
it we must save society that's the plan
all right guys let's talk about start
mail
you know free email services like gmail
and yahoo aren't really free you pay
with your privacy internet giants bank
on exploiting your data by selling it to
the highest bidder your business plan
google's got it your medical records
yahoo can sell them to drug companies
personally i don't want to open myself
up to identity theft and i can't imagine
you do either that's why i suggest using
start mail it makes email safe again
start mail keeps email private period
when you delete an email in start mail
it's gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazon's which
means they can't be put out of business
like parlor switching start mail is
seamless too you can easily transfer all
of your current email data so there's no
starting from scratch you get unlimited
anonymous aliases this feature protects
your main email address from spam and
phishing attacks so that people can't
sell your info and they can be deleted
at any time i keep saying the way
forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value the service
startmail provides your cyber security
has never been more at risk take control
of your privacy with start mail
before it's too late start securing your
email privacy with start mail sign up
today and you'll get fifty percent off
your first year go to start mail dot com
slash ruben that's start mail start with
the t s-t-a-r-t mail.com ruben for fifty
percent off your first year
startmail.com
reuben and now back to me all right so
there was a really really crazy viral
video yesterday and i'm sure some of you
have seen it but if yeah if you have
seen it it's worth watching again and if
you haven't seen it we we had to show
you this video it's deeply disturbing i
mean it was it was sort of chills up the
spine disturbing there is a show up in
quebec in french canada hosted by a
woman named julie snyder and they
brought on some kids to talk about
mandates and vaccines and what should
happen to people
and well just listen vaccine result we
truly don't insult those our people
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
i mean
you see what we've done to children
okay so i don't know everything about
those kids individually and i'm not
making it about those kids and let's not
have anyone dox those kids i know my
audience would do that kind of thing
but do you see what we have done to
children do you see what we've done to
society the adults cheering them on yes
yes call the police arrest them do you
see what they're doing to society there
was a couple things in there first off
this idea guys as children as experts is
so deeply dangerous one of the things
that this reminded me of actually was
after the parkland shooting you may
remember the parkland shooting of about
three years ago at parkland high school
here in florida my friend and and
colleague now kyle kashuv was one of the
students at parkland and if you remember
all of the kids well all of the kids
actually who became
anti-second amendment advocates they all
got on the covers of all the magazines
and they all went on all the tv shows
and they did their town halls on cnn
where they attacked dana losh and marco
rubio and everything else and they
constantly were propped up by the media
then kyle eventually as the one kid who
came out of it in a public sense as a
second amendment advocate he sort of
made a name for himself through more
conservative media let's say but this
idea that kids should be thought of as
experts is so insanely dangerous that's
not to dismiss anything that these kids
have lived through as their parents have
put them in masks they've as they've
been forced to inject themselves with
things it's not to dismiss anything that
the kids at parkland or any other
shooting went through but because you're
involved in shooting doesn't mean you're
an expert
in guns and gun safety and the
constitution and our god-given rights
etc etc so they bring these kids on they
say the most authoritarian crazy things
their brains are not yet developed how
old were those kids maybe seven
something like that like they don't have
all of the faculties to really think
through the issues oh oh oh if you do
the thing that the state doesn't want
you to do call the police yeah let's get
these people out of society
this is seriously
nazi youth type stuff i am sorry if that
offends you or bothers you but nazis
didn't just show up one day we all know
this they didn't just show up one day
and it wasn't like a society was
perfectly healthy one day and then this
hitler guy showed up and then it was
like everyone went bananas and was
calling the police on their neighbors
and being like yeah let's get those
people into the into the trains right
these things happen slowly
you remember that video i played of
jordan peterson talking about this that
this is how authoritarians move you just
change things every day little slower
people stop asking questions stop
pushing back and then there's people
like don lemon who don't want people to
ask questions don't want them to do
their own research etc etc and now they
have infected
infected the brains of children
so that children
want to call the police on people who
don't want to do the thing that they
want them to do do you think this is
dangerous stuff has this thing gotten
completely out of control and yet it is
pushed and i would recommend to my
friends i know we have a lot of viewers
in canada and i know canada is a mess
and i've got at least
three i think canadian friends well i
have a couple of canadian friends who've
already moved here to florida but i have
at least three other friends who are
considering it right now it's like it's
not going to get fixed there you guys
don't have states rights justin trudeau
is out of control your media is funded
by the government like it's bad news you
should get out you should get out and
find a better place to live because
they're telling you what the next
generation is going to think so if you
think this generation of moronic leaders
like justin trudeau
are bad what do you think that kid what
do you think that seven-year-old kid is
going to be like in 20 years when he's
27 years old and he's angry and he's
pissed and the world was destroyed and
he won't even realize that it was it was
the ideas that he was fed that destroyed
the world and now he wants more power
and he realizes that he can use the
police to arrest people who do things
that he doesn't want them to do because
that's the power
that has been given over to the state i
think we've got a problem on our hand
get out of canada florida's pretty
freaking great uh all right let's do uh
one more ad for you and then we'll uh
we'll move on to the final story i want
to talk to you guys about cozy earth
i've got a lot of papers here today i'm
a paper shuffler uh you know one of the
best things about being filmed from the
waist up is that i can look like a like
business on top while being super comfy
down below for those of you who have
been working from home and participating
in multiple zoom meetings over the past
year you know exactly what i mean that's
why no gift will be more appreciated
heading into the new year than cozy
earth sheets pajamas or loungewear i
love their sweats i've been wearing them
all the time actually they are so soft
and lightweight and that's because
they're made from super soft viscous
from highly sustainable bamboo
cozy earth's bedding and loungewear are
also temperature regulating so you'll
sleep comfortably year round it's no
wonder that cosy earth has become the
betting of choice for interior designers
and celebrities cozy earth is so
confident you'll love their products you
can try anything risk-free with their
hundred night trial
if you don't love it return it for a
hund within 100 days for free so this
new year give the gift that will be
appreciated every single night cozy
earth bedding and loungewear and now my
audience can save 35 off on cozy earth
bedding and loungewear just go to
cozyearth.com enter my promo code dave
and save 35 percent hurry that's 35 off
at cosyearth.com promo code cozier.com
and now back to me i'm telling you guys
the sweats are absolutely incredible
okay we got one more story for you today
that i thought
really would be a nice way to end the
show today and illustrative of what's
going on here in the world right now and
why a humble guy like me who just wanted
to go out to california and make it
that's not a gratuitous use of
california by the way i'm making a point
about california
i just wanted to go out there and make
it and i did it i did eight years there
and i did the thing you do when you go
to california i became a success and
then i fled uh but why a guy like me had
to flee
and it's not just me there are quite
literally hundreds of thousands if not
at this point at least almost a million
people who are in the middle of this
migration process we are watching a
rather extraordinary uh rejiggering of
the entire map politically culturally we
are watching the red and the blue split
i know a lot of people are upset by that
but in some ways i think there's a lot
of good arguments for it and it's
actually okay and your state should
matter more than the federal government
et cetera et cetera and there's a lot of
evidence now that this is happening all
over all over the country and it's not
just california that people
are fleeing
so we've got some info here from becker
news the evidence is now in that
authoritarian covid policies have become
extremely unpopular since the covid
pandemic in july 2020 to july 2021
americans have fled blue states
meanwhile states that banned vaccine
mandates saw a surge in population in
the aggregate so of course you guys know
that we're going to show you a chart
here there's a map for you and just take
a look at the map and what you are
seeing basically is that all of the blue
states with some minor exceptions people
are fleeing people are getting the freak
i almost said the other f word but
they're really pushing me on that these
days they're getting out of the blue
states they're getting out of states
that are endlessly locked down
and they are moving to red states and
not only are they moving to red states
but you guys know this all of these
ridiculous politicians like gretchen
whitmer the governor of michigan and
gavin newsom
and you know up in california is that
one gratuitous i'll throw in five bucks
for that one just for saying gavin
newsom's name you know what every time i
say his name i'll throw in five bucks so
that's it so start the tally all right
um
these people vacation here
aoc vacations in florida eric swalwell
vacations in florida these people don't
believe their own policies they don't
believe their own nonsense
they want to destroy their states and i
think they're doing it quite well bill
de blasio you know people talk about
bill de blasio the socialists who rule
in new york city a lot of people are
like he was a failure look at new york
city now the homelessness the drug use
the mass migration all of this stuff and
it's like was he a failure or did he do
exactly what a socialist would want to
do i'm pretty sure that he did this is
quite extraordinary if you look at the
map conor can we pull that map up again
this is really incredible stuff
california has lost roughly 367
000 people that is a crazy crazy number
florida on the other hand and hopefully
all of these people know what they're
fleeing and what they're going to vote
for once they're here has gained 220
000 people um
like the proof is in the pudding the
proof is in the pudding right
do you know anyone because i don't do
you know anyone in your own life i would
really love to hear it please contact us
one way or another who was like you know
what i can't take it in florida anymore
with my ability to make my own decisions
i'm moving to new york
like it sounds ridiculous but you could
see someone being like you know i've
lived in new york city my entire life
and i've never seen more crime and it
doesn't seem safe and the businesses are
all closed and they've got these vaccine
mandates and the people who are in
charge don't even abide by them i'm
moving to florida like that does make
sense right so
you don't even have to look at the stats
right i can read stats to you but like
think about your own life think about
what you're doing in your own life think
about the places you aspire to be
think about the places that other people
aspire to be think about the places that
people want to leave it's like nobody
actually
i do know one person who moved to new
york city in all of the last two years
and believe it or not it was my
mother-in-law because she fell in love
she actually fell in love and the guy
great guy
i'm not gonna name him right here but a
really really wonderful guy
uh lives in new york city i don't know
how long they're going to stay there
but she fell in love and moved to new
york city so i guess strange things have
happened but the point is guys you see
what's going on here and and just to add
a little bit more on this uh there's
some info here from the daily mail in
terms of people's political leanings
changing right now as well a new survey
conducted by gallup revealed that 47
percent of americans identified as
republican or republican leaning at the
end of 2021 that's a nine percent
increase in support
from the start of the year so what i
thought was extraordinary about that is
it doesn't surprise me obviously that
more people are sort of leaning right
right they're going okay
the wokesters the leftists whatever is
remaining of the same liberals none of
this works the democrats are basically
all crazy liars i can't you know there's
joe manchin he's all right you got
kirsten cinema and maybe tulsi is still
a democrat i don't know but there's
really just nothing left there there are
no sort of sane liberal pundits i would
put let's put bill maher on the side or
okay you can put him where you want to
put him in that there's just nothing
left over there so as i often say on the
show
you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a democrat i don't
know that i really consider myself a
republican a republican is part of a
political party you're part of the
republican political party like i don't
need to be part of a political party per
se i think that's sort of an old-school
way of looking at things but do the
conservative set of views to the basic
ideas of freedom and rule of law
and personal choice are those a better
set of ideas than whatever the freak is
going on with this collectivist
authoritarian lunacy and this obsession
with race and gender
and state power and taxing the [ __ ] out
of you it's like the choice is yours man
and and everyone gets it everyone gets
it
and
i have nothing else to say about it uh
guys we got one more ad for you because
we actually you know we've been a little
light on shows no no we don't
well
that's it well i'll give you an ad
people if you're watching this program
right now i'm dave rubin host of the
reuben report we are now live every day
every weekday that is
at 11 a.m
eastern
man that's going to take time that is
it's so lodged in my brain
we are now live from miami florida every
day at 11 a.m eastern and do me a solid
if you haven't subscribed to our youtube
channel would you subscribe over there
and by the way i'm hearing a lot from
people in the last couple weeks about
being unsubscribed so just make sure
you're subscribed even if you think that
you are
really obviously though i want to push
people of course to rumble because i
really think we are building an
incredible parallel economy with rumble
and locals and everything else so please
go subscribe over on rumble you can
watch on blaze tv and i'm dave rubin
doing a commercial for dave rubin on
dave rubin's reuben report have a great
day everybody
you